to me it's just a price the problem with
a lot of traditional stuff right now is
they're dying so they're charging you
more do you know that newspaper ads cost
more now than they did 10 years ago it's
a joke and do you know many people keep
paying it because that's how we built
this darn place
the only thing I care about with
marketing is selling stuff marketing is
an engine for business the problem and
the opportunity is is marketing is going
through the biggest shift it's gone
through since we transitioned from a
predominant radio consuming Society to a
predominant television Society the
internet is now 30 years old you know
it's really starting to hit maturity
where they are now and what's happening
on the modern day internet is remarkable
what's even more remarkable is how many
people in this room in this beautiful
city and in this country continue to
underestimate the power of the modern
marketing and how much they continue to
overestimate yesterday the concept of
humanity is very simple I'm going to
overvalue yesterday because it's not
scary I know it for a small group of
people that I roll with in Silicon
Valley and others they overestimate
tomorrow they're like if you're not on
VR selling cars you're an idiot there's
like nine people using VR I'm watching
everybody
way way over value yesterday I promise
this room has a lot of heart for
yesterday what I want for all of you is
I want you to be obsessed with today for
example today if you know what Tick Tock
is and if you know what Instagram reels
are Facebook has a version called reels
all the cool kids are doing everything
on Tick Tock and Instagram because
that's the new wave meanwhile because so
few people are making content for
Facebook reels yet there are tens and
hundreds of millions of people consuming
those reels the supply and demand of
attention and output is off kilter and
one of the biggest opportunities in
marketing this second is doing videos
and pictures on Facebook reels to sell
stuff it is the framework of our society
the biggest reason the world's confused
right now is they don't understand that
the attention of our society is Shifting
so fast to new platforms think about
commercials Super Bowl's the best I'm on
CNBC saying these are a steal at seven
million dollars a spot why because a
hundred plus Americans will actually
watch it meanwhile so streaming is
eating up all television except Sports
how many people here now have Netflix or
Hulu or Amazon Prime and are consuming
shows on that raise your hand I don't
know if you know this these are not 20
year olds you're watching Hulu and
Netflix which means every minute you're
doing that is the minute you're not
watching cable
it's a minute you're not watching local
television and oh by the way the random
times you find yourself on cable and
regular television predominantly
watching sports when the commercial
comes on I promise you're not consuming
it even this crowd is grabbing their
phone and doing something or going to
the bathroom or whatever you're doing
but I promise you you're not excited for
a Jeep going up a mountain telling you
it's 3.99. consumer Behavior has shifted
and the amount of money that is being
wasted is staggering meanwhile digital's
no dream either the amount of money
being wasted in digital in modern
marketing is profound the amount of
brands that are overspending on
programmatic banner ads on the bottom of
espn.com that nobody here sees is
staggering influencer marketing one of
the greatest ways to do business in
marketing today one of the worst you
could pay somebody five thousand dollars
to do a campaign and you can get nothing
you can get somebody for 800 bucks and
you get a ton this is like the ROI of a
basketball the ROI of a basketball for
LeBron James is a billion dollars the
ROI for me is negative four thousand
dollars
I've torn both of my meniscus the ROI
for a piano for me zero Billy Joel a
billion a lot of people come up to me
and say Gary social media doesn't work
I've been doing it for a year it doesn't
work I go the data is very clear it
works it doesn't work for you because
you suck at it when I talk to CMOS the
most interesting thing of my day we will
play a video and they will look at it or
we'll show them a picture and they will
look at it and they believe that their
subjective opinion of the video is the
right answer the audacity of humans
deciding I don't like that picture we
didn't like that post The Audacity Of
not understanding it is not about your
subjective opinion it is about the Quant
and qual data after the post is made to
get the Insight or the sale the lack of
humility in marketing today is
staggering they are completely
completely confused about what's
happening because that was what was
required in the Mad Men era it was your
subjective opinion opinion and you ran
it we do not have to do that in modern
marketing the math and the Quantum qual
of social gives us the insights to then
allow us to scale the marketing
campaigns my biggest problem is when
people make decisions for their ego
people would rather see a commercial
during their baseball game for their
company and waste money than not see the
tick tocks in Instagram and make more
money I will never to the day I die
understand that ego and yesterday is
hurting a lot of people from growing